oh yeah like everyone in LA is from
Chicago or at least how does that make
it everyone that's making it is from
Chicago to Chicago a great migration but
dude
the honestly no it's like here's the
thing at the hint of Midwest helps them
does something like Ike Barinholtz right
he loves the Cubs you know he loves all
Chicago he's from the bear holders yeah
they're from Chicago right
but he's also hip he likes Joy Division
I know that for a fact
oh my god yeah I know that because I
know him right yeah he loves Joy
Division but he also can wear a face
ball cap right and be a normal American
right and also at that on top of that he
smiles got a little gap between his
teeth right have a hint of they have the
cosmopolitan hip nastain Street in their
blood normals yes that's what I'm saying
Chicago has a really great sense of
community it's very rude see [ __ ] yeah
and they all stay friends they all stay
connected LA is very more of an
opportunistic vibe here
right yeah that's what it is I will tell
you the main difference people in
Chicago want people to do well Wow they
just do cheering for everyone and it's
one of the reasons that I think people
don't get that big while staying in
Chicago maybe there's not this cutthroat
their hard-working is [ __ ] and they want
other people to do better they are
genuinely happy they are inclusive and
so when they come out here they end up
finding people from Chicago yes and they
help each other look like Ike Barinholtz
John Peron halls but here's connection
Seth Meyers
right and Ike Seth Seth Meyers and Ike
and and in the parents's then the
McArthur brothers Hayes and his brothers
on that new show the mick right they're
all friends they're all they're not from
the same family
but they're all from the same generation
and demographic and they are all bros
they all go to bat with each other they
pull each other up right and that's what
I also I love about Chicago you guys are
good people man all right and that's
legit and you guys have cook with Taos
Keys from there but you also with Taos
key knows those other guys with tusky
we'll see whatever we toss skis friends
with the Barinholtz is all as well Bobby
Jimenez my point is is gist is that you
know and you know and I want to I want
to do that community with Koreans and
Asians I'm in yeah I know I'm not gonna
name names all right but I know a buddy
listen you've named enough names listen
to me right now if you're a [ __ ]
executive at Sony Studios right we don't
notice no no or or any agency and you're
Asian and you don't have agent clients
or you don't book Asians in your [ __ ]
movies like on a constant you know basis
basis what are you doing of the people
like when we do this podcast we always
have Asians on here do you know why we
want to help our own okay we do George
we do but we're mostly just inclusive to
everybody we are inclusive to everybody
[Music]
no I've had beans [ __ ] in here I've
had Punjab xand [ __ ] yeah and the
blacks and they have done the wife
they've done this podcast as well jungle
you're not saying you only help your own
you're saying that your manual but I'm
mindful of it it's like when I talk to
Adam Egan at the comedy books The Comedy
Store the other night he was like I he
goes I go Sherri Shepherd may or may not
show up because I wish you did because
she's great people know her from shows -
Sherri Shepherd right you know she is
right but he goes it's also you know I
we need you and her on the line up I go
why because it gives it a different
dynamic right you can't just have a
bunch of white people go up
he's a mindful of that
we're mindful here as well mindful group
or a mindful group its diversifying
that's why so to executives who have
power Atma it's not about the bottom
dollar sometimes dollar bottom was it
yeah bottom dollar all right sometimes
you have to take a risk and go you know
what this movie is supposed to be about
Asians we got a book Asians in it like
that [ __ ] what's that twenty-one oh
yeah yeah when the actual story is the
stores about appreciation guys from MIT
that go to [ __ ] Vegas are dying and
then the first three leaves are white is
not making the right decision now we're
doing bad there competin I think it's
changing thanks for changing slowly now
look Kevin Spacey produced it now look
what happened Karma
[Music]